you faced some proper fears in the  making of  this film they made you go on a roller  coaster  well here's the ridiculous thing they is  me  i developed and produced this film so  you would think that i wouldn't have put  terrifying things out there like singing  on stage which is something i hate or  riding on roller coasters something that  i loathe  look at this oh god i was crying that  those are tears  um that sweet girl next to me the  beautiful actress jenna ortega  she had to sit next to me she said that  her fingers were almost wrenched off i  was holding her  squeezing her hand so hard most of the  take was not usable because i was  screaming  jenna her character's name was katy  i was cursing i was praying um it was a  very it was a big day for me i had to  have my big girl panties on this  yesterday sounds horrible